you guys it's the 15 year anniversary of
Legally Blonde you know what that means
we gotta do the bend and snap
so you pretend you're dropping something
and then yeah oh yeah man is snap you
gotta love it Reese Witherspoon she have
to everybody to break out their pink to
celebrate Legally Blonde at 15 and when
we heard that well we were all in mm-hm
and we were first on the set back of the
day so here is our way back Wednesday
Elwood style or the whole movie sort of
a play on dumb blondes and how you know
when a person looks at certain way you
perceive them as things or a stupid it's
one of a kind I thought the chin poked a
year ago so if you're trying to sell it
to me for full price you picked the
wrong girl why now we were with Reese
then just twenty four years old playing
what will become one of her most famous
roles Elle Woods the girly blonde who
floors everyone when she's admitted to
Harvard you got into Harvard Law wet
like it's hard on way back Wednesday
here are four Legally Blonde secrets
number one Risa actually considered
herself to be a bit of a ditz
every day I get to my mark and I can't
remember in my lives
why now I'm always like no I'm heavy
dumb blonde moment all the peroxide
seeping into my skull so you're breaking
up with me because I'm too blonde number
two a co-star crash-mat Davies who
played Warner the x-rays tries to get
back was really into her
that's had a crush on recent I was 15 so
to actually get a chance to work with
her it was kind of a treat you didn't
tell me that I'm married and I know he
likes my husband Eliza that husband Ryan
Philippi attended both of Reese's
premieres in LA and the Hamptons where
he gushed about her and their daughter
Ava then only 21 months old we love
being parents
and she's amazing at it and I love it
but at the LA premiere Ryan said this
about his wife playing a scorned to act
just five years before they would split
up
that's the one thing I have to kind of
you know that's the one gripe I have
like it speaks just two years earlier
the pair starred alongside rhesus future
Legally Blonde co-star selma Blair she's
been a friend since cruel intentions and
I would you know act with her any day
that leads us to Legally Blonde secret
number three Selma and Reeves were
actually neighbors we love to cross the
street from each other should come over
when I got locked out of the house she
had my keys and stuff so we're really
close and and it's been great because we
get to see each other everyday and hang
out and finally number four Arisa was
dying to be a college grad like al but
wasn't up for Law School
I would love to be able to be a doctor a
pediatric surgeon that's what I really
want to be well you might remember that
wreaths made a sequel in 2003 and she
had said that she'd actually like to
make a third one in which L becomes
president and boy is timing right for
that story